speaking of feedback Trump just won the
CPAC straw poll
and he won it by a country mile 62
percent of the respondents at the straw
poll
voted for Trump
Ron DeSantis did not show up to CPAC he
still came in second though he got 20
third place went to a Michigan
billionaire Nam Perry Johnson so does
that matter well the CPAC straw poll
it's got actually a pretty decent record
in predicting the nominee not perfect
it's a little bit of a mixed bag some
straw polls though don't matter at all
the CPAC one does a little bit in 2020
obviously they picked Trump in 2016 the
CPAC straw poll picked Cruz and Cruz was
the number two guy he almost got the
nomination but it went to Trump in 2012
the CPAC straw poll picked Romney 2008
also picked Romney so they got that one
wrong in 2000 they picked Bush they got
that one right Dole in 96 they got that
one right Buchanan in 92 they got that
one wrong Reagan in 1980 they got that
one obviously right so it's a mixed bag
but Trump winning it I think is a pretty
decent sign